and what about the kind of um you know
the the
stereotypical image like whipping people
and things like that does that happen it
does happen but actually a lot of people
are not into uh pain yeah
okay I understand that yeah yeah I mean
pain and how it transfers to pleasure is
actually quite
linked but there's a lot of things that
people have around their relationship to
pain that helps them to avoid it and so
a lot of people don't ask necessarily to
be whipped to feel torture but
it does get asked and it is a really
nice skill that I enjoy and there is a
lot of catharsis when you receive it and
when you give in but uh does everybody
want it no